good evening members of the public and
members of the council welcome to the
overun scrutiny committee
held on thursday 28th of july
my name is michael helm i'm chairman of
this committee
members with our lives we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphone therefore
can i ask that when you invite to speak
you remember to turn on your microphone
and turn it off when you're finished
please reference a page or paragraph
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
um i'm going to break from tradition and
we'll go around the table and if members
could all introduce themselves please
i'm councillor helm i'm councillor
spencer
brian beale
council messenger
how's it going in attendance
councillor fluka in attendance
councillor morgan
councillor mays
councillor bell
that's the stamp in attendance
councillor hubena
council appeal thank you very much for
that members uh that's for the benefit
of the public because they might not who
you know who you are
okay um
next i'd like to thank councillor bell
for excellent leadership of this
committee
thank you very much no problem absolute
pleasure yeah chad
can't go without thank you thank you
very much right
um apologies for absence please berna
can you um i know yeah berna can you um
have we got any apologies for absence
okay
minutes of the last meeting it's
recommended the minutes of the meeting
held on
whenever it was found on pages are
proved at a true and accurate record i
so move do i have a seconder for that
motion
which one shall i take counselor bell
and councillor mays okay
uh can we do this by a cent
agreed okay
when we've got declarations of interest
disclose the existence and nature of any
disglobal pecuniary interest other
registerable interests and non-regional
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
9 and pat an appendix b of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
needs arise during the meeting
have we got any
declarations
right
just a quick one have we missed out for
or did you say there weren't any
public participating
we were just doing declarations of
interest then
that was four before the disclosure oh
declarations of interest and sorry
so there's no public participation no
there's no public directivation
okay
we move
on to the report
uh agenda item six noted motion please
see below the following suggested script
oh that's for me
the counselor referred this notice of
motion to the committee for
consideration
as our remit is mainly one of scrutiny
in review for now rather than look at
look to discuss it without more
information to understand what lies
behind these issues we simply need to
receive
it and decide how to deal with it since
the nature to be looked
to be looked
at are clear
and the council has asked us to look at
this
we can at least agree to add this to our
work plan
the committee's normal process would
however
be to refer to the scrutiny request to
our working group which will be
appointed later this evening to seek
further information and then report back
to us
on the actual scope of scrutiny and a
plan of how to go ahead
i therefore recommend to the committee
that the best way forward well i'm going
to leave that for a minute councillor
fluke who's just going to read out his
his emotions thank you joan i i don't
think i'm required to and i won't make
it terribly sorry and i do apologize mr
chairman if i may just intercede with a
question of process
and i do apologize
explaining it then but i apologize i
didn't quite get it clear in my mind
well i nearly got to that but
i just wanted to question why we are
hearing the motion itself rather than
just making an agreement to refer it to
the working group well councillor flukes
are entitled to talk to his motion
regardless but that is a clear breaking
procedure and process of this working
group as previously agreed can i have
assistance on that tara please
does that clear a break or not
cheryl yeah so i think the um it is
not typical for overview scrutiny to
scrutinize an item without having been
through the working group process
and so obviously you're preamble there
you were talking about
it going back to the working group and
then
the idea being that the committee are
being asked to add this item to the work
plan
and then it would be reviewed online and
brought back
thorough debate
is anyone happy with that response
counselor fluker thank you chairman i i
wasn't actually planning to put the
motion and i think i was just about
started to say that when um when i gave
way um chairman i'm more than happy for
this to go to a working group i think
it's quite a bit of a complex piece of
work and i'm sure that all members on
this committee will want to look at the
decision uh at atlasford's council where
as a result of members unreasonable
behavior
over a million pounds worth of costs
awarded against the council and there's
lots of other information background in
this yeah i would i would propose that
the committee considers it goes to go
into a working group i'm not sure if
it's the working group that you refer to
later on because i think they'll already
they'll have a lot of work to do anyway
chairman and the and the uh remit of
that working group is slightly different
and i think that a working group that
look at this member should be mindful
of who was involved in this
decision-making process and of course
there are a lot of members who sit on
this committee who actually weren't on
the council when this happened
so i would be more than happy chairman
for you to refer this to a working group
but i'd ask members to consider having a
pacific working group just to deal with
this so that they can deal with it in a
timely manner unlike i was then thank
you okay thank you
bill um mr chairman that again is a
departure from process and um i'm
i'm asking for i'm i'm rather concerned
that councillor fluger is concerned that
we might not be able to deal with this
properly as
we would deal with anything else yeah
and indeed um
council helm you as the chair of
overview and scrutiny in fact seconded
this motion so
you know we are asking to trust in yes
of course we are yes and i think we are
honorable counsellors yes and i think
the public may reasonably place its
trust in us
if we follow the standard procedure and
we'll refer this to the existing working
group or at least the working group as
it will exist by the end of this okay
then right that's fine everyone happy
with that
yes
okay right
we'll move on to
to agree to receive the notice of motion
are we agreeing to the motive motion
yes
agree to add the item to our work plan
and agree to refer
yeah yeah yeah yeah the work that the
work plan is a working group
and it comes online and agreed to refer
the matter to our working group for
further consideration and report back to
us
okay we finally got there thank you very
much
we move on to
there's the next one
sorry my computer hasn't got everything
on it
yeah
okay we'll move on to that then please
and are you going to present this report
please
supply and they asked a series of
questions about the land supply
so they wanted a clear understanding of
what's led to the present position and
why this issue was not identified and
reported earlier
what is proposed to insult the present
difficulty with the five-year land
supply
what impact this has on the local
development plan and the impending
review of the local development plan
and details of the strategic side of
planning applications coming forward and
the projected time for reaching the
housing plan
so in the paper
i've set out what the five-year land
supply is
takes five years worth of housing
to take a target
to housing targeting the local homework
and it's five years worth of that plus a
five percent buffer which you have to
put on
that's a um in the national guidance so
you either have five 10 or 27
to your
five-year supply
depending on
how you're delivering housing so
moulding district is a 9
um so we're not 10 and we're not at 20
percent so we're not significantly under
delivering we're we're okay so the five
percent offers around choice of
competition to the market
so we work out what five year suppliers
and i've set out in the paper how we how
we do that and i'm not proposing to go
through it in any any fine detail if
you've got any questions then please ask
me
um
any question
you ready for questions then
hello
councillor paula
hi hi ann so um you know that i sent you
a series of written questions about the
um report
and at 5.1 um
on the report
the question that i asked you there was
noting that the inspector must surely
have thought that the build-out rate for
strategic site 2d
would have been in line with the
trajectory in the ldp
surely he would have looked at evidence
of this in the examination
whether we now have the evidence of this
or not is it likely that the build-out
rate will be as slow as countryside is
now claiming was my question
um
and you came back to me on that
um saying that um
the inspector at the examination must
have been told that site 2d was starting
in 2018-19
and the trajectory trajectory sets out
their yearly build-out rate and that
countryside should have agreed with the
council
both the officers at the examination and
countryside would have confirmed this to
the inspector
unless there was someone else at the
examination challenging this the
inspector may have quizzed it but would
have accepted it
the reality is countryside have only
just started
2022-23 four years after they should
have they have told us they will build
50 a year so at the moment if we change
that the first time we go to appeal any
developer with any intelligence is going
to say we are making it up and they
would be right
inspectors take a really dim view of
this kind of behavior from councils well
i was really curious about that because
i know site 2d quite well because
obviously part of it is in my world i've
got a little plan of 2d here
actually
and i've been speaking to the site
managers in fact i've been on a number
of visits because obviously i'm working
towards um setting up with councillor
edwards the community liaison panel on
the site and for the development phase
which is a project we have
so
they explained this to me very carefully
they're actually countryside are only
building four little phases as we all
know we're going to have 10 11 and 12
coming to council which has been
purchased by railway and we will be
built out by bellway
i understand that on parcels
three six and seven they've today had
offers
and that only leaves the parcels um
where the school and medical center and
sports pitches and pavilion allotments
etc are that will be built last
so i asked them about this slow
build-out rate
and do you know what the site managers
there said to me it'll all be done
within seven years
that's very different that's very
different to what we've got before us
and they said i could give you a bit
more sorry a bit more detail to anne so
that she's aware
that they're saying that they're going
to have three developers with site
offices open for sale the sale offices
running at the same time so they'll be
building concurrently
so this this figure of 50.
yeah no no i just want to make sure ends
got the detail there yes good okay
thanks
we've got what sam say
but those people who are buying those
sites they will probably have to put
planning permissions in
so at the moment they haven't done that
so when they do
and it comes through system then we can
start adding it into the supply but
until we until they do it's just well
then you know it's what
what there's nothing
at the moment i have no completions come
through at the moment at all
well that's
we do know that um 10 11 and 12 is a
planning application which has actually
been been delayed from coming to
committee for some console t responses
and actually we should have already had
that by now but haven't because of that
so that's 10 11 and 12 i think is 267
houses if i remember rightly
on the estate at the moment they're
laying out the relief road and all sorts
of other things ready for the housing
the guys i've been speaking to there are
the project they're site managers and
project managers and have been working
on it from the beginning
um interestingly as another point they
gave me their reasons for the delay and
they blame it almost entirely on the
failure of the flood alleviation scheme
and and what followed from that
um as well as as well as
no okay can you answer that point and
about the flood alleviation scheme
disputes about the flood alleviation
scheme and it did delay
the project coming forward
um
as far as what goes on on the side we
will we continually review it
so in the five year supply of this year
for the first time i've actually put um
sentence which reserves the right to go
back in six months and review it
so we could publish again in six months
but then there is a slight danger but i
just want to caveat that with if we go
back in six months we don't have any
evidence and it's gone down
effectively we'll be publishing a figure
that's less than it is now
so that's why we've only reserved the
right we haven't said we're definitely
going to do it
can i let some other members say
my strong suit but i'm just looking at
uh the in 4.2
uh it's got homes delivered 2014 to 31 3
20 22 was 2232
and in 4.3 it's got the number of homes
1550.
can you just explain to me how those
figures relate to each other if indeed
they do
what was the question
right sorry let's start again i'm i'm
just interested to know you've got in
4.2 you're showing at the table there
that
2232 homes were delivered in the period
2014 to the 31st of march 2022.
that's on page 14 anne
is what we should have delivered
against what we have delivered so we've
got a shortfall of
248 homes which have to be added into
the final supply it's not that this
isn't a very big shortfall no no i
understand that but below that in the
table in 4.3 you've got number of homes
1550.
so i'm just wondering where that figure
appears
fine but that's the five years so you
went up to that so every five years at
the moment we should be delivering
1550 homes right
right we've been under delivered by 248
homes right and then we had five percent
onto that so then he ended up so every
five years at the moment we should be
delivering 1887.90
middle or nine hours homes in the
district
and then you take off that your
commitment to what you've already got in
the bag that you can deliver over five
years
thanks very much thanks that's kind
you haven't asked to speak council
passenger but i will i did actually
write to you actually michael i haven't
been receiving the emails lately so it's
my fault okay carry on well thank you
for letting me speak and and is that
including windfall sites
you take yes everything that's gone to
planning permission that can be
delivered within five years
and this includes windfall we have we
are including our windfall
yeah okay
i have two sheets i've got a strategic
allocation spreadsheet and i've got a
spreadsheet which has all the film and
developments on it
okay thank you
did you want me to carry on with the um
yes yeah yeah please
so why haven't we achieved a five-year
supply it is basically because
the amount of parenting that we
the amount of fountain that can be
delivered within five years
is not sufficient
to cover the five-year requirement of
our housing and then so
so what you need to do
is you're not granting enough planning
provisions you won't have enough
permissions you won't have enough in the
bank
so to speak but you haven't got an
amount of housing that is actually going
to be built during that period and
that's what that basically wasn't got a
heavy supply
you haven't got a large
under supply it's actually very low
but it's it's what's going to come
forward in that five years that's that's
that's what the issue is so it's not the
fact that the um the trajectory
was
it's not the fact that the approach that
you had in the local plan was wrong it's
to the trajectory was not accurate and
so it's the pace of what's come forward
isn't there a difference between
deliberate deliverability and delivered
i mean are they not two different things
yeah so
our estimation of
deliverability is is what we think but
what's actually delivered isn't
necessarily sort of our concern as such
we we are so we estimate don't we what
we should be building out or what is
possibly going to be built out so if we
have all the planning permissions in
then isn't that our deliverability and
then the deliverable is only what is
being built out
is that how it
what is going to works delivered and
there are some kind of roles around that
set out in national guidance so we can't
put in
outlines over ten thousands we're not
allowed to do that um
outlines under ten houses can go in
we can't put in things that we know that
are not going to be delivered so you can
you can't see you what you have to do is
you have to either get the information
from the developers which is what we're
doing on the big strategic sites
anything under 10 houses just
automatically goes into the internet
but because we don't have lots and lots
of windfall developments
it's not supplementing
your strategic size yep
was there any other questions from
members
council hubler
well it's no surprise
that we can't understand what's been
proposed in this document
and this is going to be a public
what
worries me is this is going to be a
public document and if we don't
understand that how are our residents
going to
understand it
and difficult one again
sorry
it's quite complicated
you know councils across the country and
struggle with this i have to say
it's it's the one thing that is quite
complex it's a bit like trying to work
out your healthy requirement you know
it's a complex um it's a complex thing
and it kind of takes quite a lot of
briefings and discussions to understand
it
thank you for that counselor bell you
wanted to ask a question
curveball why in this is there
absolutely no mention of the impact
covid has had on our build rape it's
like the elephant in the room not a
single mention
and but that's because it hasn't really
had an impact
it didn't really have an impact on
content it doesn't mean it's not going
to have an impact though
because the cost of materials
is still rising waters are still rising
and i've noticed this year
rather than last year that the number of
completions seems to be going down
so i think the impact nationally on the
building industry will come will come
further on this year and maybe next year
we might have a right of reply yesterday
i'll let you this once
i'm just i'm afraid that's that's that's
just not true we've had sites closed the
sites were closed over the kobe period
it has had a huge impact
it seems to be quite steady
we are still we are still building quite
high speed
let me just get council stamp first
councillor stamp you've been waiting a
long while there we go no chairman i
just want to know the process are we
waiting for everybody all the members to
debate and then we ask all our questions
at the end or are we allowed to ask when
the members you know each each segment
and it's time to present the report yeah
and i'm taking questions at the same
time okay so we can speak at the same
time when the members are finished
because i didn't speak on the previous
one because i thought you wanted us to
speak at the end of the debate so
we can speak yeah okay can i speak yeah
sorry thank you
thank you can i just go to um 5.2 of the
report and it says given the passage of
time the lack of discussion minutes from
any previous working group council
meeting or
local plan examination session is not
possible to show for definite why the
above prediction was chosen as the
housing
trajectory trajectory or what disputes
disputes of conversations took place in
the examination chairman i find that
really difficult how can we actually
look back at history to improve it or
not make the same mistakes if we've got
no minutes and nobody knows what goes on
i think you'll find that the previous
administration before was newbies came
in even though we're near the end of our
term um attended that and i think there
was a lot of knowledge that was around
when the previous ldp was being put
together so that's the the first point i
also want to to raise um
the the inspector raised many questions
about the delivery and the lack of
infrastructure so i'm i'm really
struggling to find
it it isn't it isn't sort of we knew it
was going to happen okay as far as i'm
concerned if you listen to the tapes if
you listen to and you read the reports
and everything or you attended the
hearings the inspector was more than
helpful
to get the uh plan through he accepted
this plan it was his plan that's been
adopted by this council so i'm really
struggling with the fact that now we are
in this position when we shouldn't have
been that plan if it's as bad as what it
says in the some of the reports and some
of what officers have been saying to
members it's not fit for purpose
i'm really struggling chairman and and i
think i could go through this bit by bit
but would be here all night so i'm going
to wait if i can come back at the end to
see what the other members think but i
need think it needs more of a drilling
down thank you thank you chairman and
sorry it's back to you again
work for the council um and so we don't
have any records of what was said so all
the things that we
we're only making we're looking at the
plan in hindsight really and trying to
think well okay we won't do x y and said
again but we'll make sure we don't do
that again and we're more actually i
mean everything's done digitally now so
they're not keeping records or maybe
they were kept in them
you know on paper
won't happen because you know we
digitize everything we record meetings
we take minutes you know it's just not
going to happen again and so it is
difficult for us
to say
why that trajectory was accepted
you know if that trajectory was placed
in front of us today
it could be that we wouldn't accept it
for the various reasons i've set out in
the report there are things that today
we wouldn't do
but that's because you know it's it's a
different set of officers
and you know i've got
some planet for 30 years and that's done
it for i don't know how many years it's
probably nearly the same so i don't know
what
what went on basically we don't know
we can't change it we can't change
what's happened and it went on the
surface to be honest on the surface
the
strategy that was put forward is is
sound because it's putting growth in
sustainable places so you know it's a
sound sustainable strategy it's just in
hindsight things haven't come forward as
quickly as we would have liked
does that help you
chairman it does but i i can't accept
that there's no notes and no minutes
this council would be operating
unlawfully if the world hang on hang on
please it that i can't believe that
that's not the case they maybe are
downstairs and then maybe should be
digitalized or whatever the saying is
put on so if you can see them and i
think that's no excuse we can't turn
around to our residents and say oh well
we're in this position because we didn't
take minutes and i'm not having to go
and i don't want ann to respond i just
think it's really important that anybody
wants this
previous
i i think that's totally acceptable it
must have been presented at the inquiry
at the inspectors hearing for the
inspector to see it chairman so there
must have been something somewhere that
goes behind that ldp thank you thank you
um can i take councillor fluke next
thank you sorry
sorry councillor yep so just just to
answer a few questions we must forget
that we actually submitted two local
development plans and the first one
failed but even though we submitted two
the first one the planning inspector
accepted the trajectory now david
coleman who led on the ldp worked very
hard with regards to trajectory and we
mustn't forget that we had a planning
and licensing committee then which was
very much locked into the local
development plan and and knowing
councillor channel as i do who chaired
that for several years and in fact she
stayed on the committee to see through
the local development plan if no one has
a copy of those minutes and notes she
will so i hope she's been asked because
to me that would have been the right way
to go so i don't think it's right really
to to criticize the council
um over the trajectory because two
planning inspectors accepted it so and
and the other thing is with regards to
covid
when the covert crisis was
taking off
all the local authorities were asking to
have
their delivery numbers extended the
five-year housing land supply that's uh
extended by a year or two years so that
we could play catch-up
and the then
the then housing minister i think was
stephen clark who's now the
no no
stephen clark he he well he is now the
treasury number two at the treasury and
he wouldn't give way to that but
chairman i mean what members need to
understand is that
the tale of the five-year housing land
supply is actually wagged by the
developers and they have no incentive
really to get their houses out there
because if the five-year housing land
supply fails then happy days for them
because they just bring forward so
um
you know and this the whole situation is
going to be exacerbated because i you
know
we're going into a recession we don't
know what that's going to look like with
regards to the housing market but it's
going to affect the whole thing but but
my my question really to uh ms ortoff
shawnan is is about policy
and the only way that you can really
counter this
is to say to developers you will develop
so many houses a year
and
we shouldn't let developers bring sole
developers have sites of a thousand
houses yeah you find that as soon as you
break them up into manageable chunks of
300 the race starts to deliver this has
been proven elsewhere so you know as we
go through the local development plan
review i hope that it's legal to do that
because i think going forward we should
do that um but with the housing land
supply i mean on the 21st of march a
planning inspector agreed with an
appellant morton district council agreed
with both that the housing land supply
is only 2.92 years so unfortunately we
are you know we are where we we are with
this and to be honest with you if we had
less houses in the in the five-year
housing land supplier we still wouldn't
be delivering for all of the reasons i
just said so i think chairman that
you know that is the hard facts that go
behind this so thank you for letting me
talk
sorry
can i take councillor largan's question
then
well
thank you mr tim
yeah
the government gave um
they gave additional
um i think it was six months worth of
housing in the housing delivery test
which is different from the five year
supply so we we we pass the housing
delivery test with flying cars okay
yeah
okay
that's the
um i will take before uh time allocation
mr chairman and it's very kind of you to
allow me to speak not being a member of
this committee i don't agree with that
2.92 years i don't think that's correct
um
i think also if you go back and thank
you for the report and and if you go
back and you look at
why we had a review
we obviously it was time because we 75
of our strategic allocations we hadn't
delivered upon so therefore the the plan
has in it legally a partial review
my question because you're the scrutiny
committee
so i would start to scrutinize why we've
thrown ourselves into a full-scale
full-on very expensive detailed review
that leaves us completely vulnerable as
a district
i believe that there's other ways of
calculating
the five-year housing land supply um i'm
not and i'm not having to go and in any
way shape or form but um there has been
uh
completions and and properties left off
for instance it said it on a
deliverability um statement
coach
uh he said well this is on some notes
that i made from a report that came in
from a
from a resident that showed some
concerns
he said uh it used a figure of 198
deliverable for 2021. the actual feed
for
2022 was 330 completions
at one point there was 271 properties
that were left off the supply and that
was conceded by officers
so
from where i sit i start to say okay are
these figures right are what council
spencer said about the build up the
potential delivery because if if a
developer is buying these parcels of
land they're going to go helpful ever to
to sell these things as quickly as they
can because sitting on a piece of land
with no return it isn't feasible for
them and they although i hear what
council fluka says i think some of that
is absolutely 100
correct but i think there's going to be
a faster trajectory of build out there
also on anne's report there's quite a
few things um that i would say in 5.5
um
about the housing growth
and if we look about the policies are
unclear whether a policy is required
um
it is debatable i mean the policies are
there it says under bullet point one
more district council's ldp policies are
not written very clearly compared to
more recent plans they have many
constraining um caveats which are
repeated throughout the ldp making it
difficult for developers to gain planet
efficiency isn't that the point why you
put the policies in the thing in the
first place so you can control where you
want the building and where you don't
want the building so i think again are
you getting all this sam yeah these are
these are this is recorded so you can go
back as well um and i think you know
when you look at it if you have no
obviously policy protection for
settlement boundaries
then you start to build that into areas
where you don't have sustainability and
you can't have deliverability because
it's about sustainable development
and i think the mppf talks about there's
a presumption in favor of sustainable
development not any development so
there's so many concerns and questions
that can be asked in this excellent
report that's been given to us
that i think it would be remiss of this
committee i know if i was sitting on
this committee i would be certain saying
putting a motion on the table now saying
that this ldp review should be
sent to full council as a recommendation
it should be a partial review and that
all the members should be looking at
this under an extraordinary general
meeting or some form of that nation to
really scrutinize and to develop
what's in here and what options there
are because at the moment mr chairman
what i see it seems there's an awful lot
of effort being put in over a long
period of time to show why we haven't
got a five-year housing land supply
rather than why we can
there's different there's different um
calculations that we could look at and
if we said if we went to the 260 that
the builds that we we initially were
looked at before the council said we'll
do 310 you know we've got covey we've
got slow downs in rates it would be very
reasonable for an inspector to look at
that and say that's a reasonable
application so i think that you know if
i if i was you there's other figures
i've got other figures here but i know
you want me to finish um
which which could be used in that for
housing van supply so i think your job
as people who are there to overrun
scrutiny as a member
i would much rather that the whole of
the council because this plan is the
councils
and it comes to the council and the
council start to get a real detailed
understanding and i would call for a
past review and i'd hope this actually
full-on very expensive and i question
unnecessary review
so that's that's how i see it and
there's so much information out there
that doesn't um challenge and because
anne's a very high professional with
lots of
great experience but there's always more
than one way to skin a cat other
districts are doing it we shouldn't sit
on our laurels because at the moment
we're open to hostile development so all
thorn can be wiped out southminster can
have
non-sustainable development you know we
are at risk here this is the most
important thing any of us sitting around
this table can get involved in and we're
allowed to do it
it's this council puts that
recommendation if this this committee
puts our recommendations through
so thank you for allowing me to speak
and would you like to reply to that
well
uh the legal requirement to do a review
is now
is it you've now hit that date actually
on i think it was the 17th of july the
council now has a legal requirement to
review their plan
so
the the 75
that the the the inspector um put into
the plan it's a kind of moon point now
because we have to do it now it's it's
not it's not about choice
um we have to review the plan um so we
what we've done is we've just started
that work a year early um so we're a bit
ahead of the game i thought i said we've
waited until now
we would not even have an issues and
options document in place
so there were planning policy working
group are going to start to have a look
at the
future housing requirement because we
now need to allocate some more land
for housing i mean maybe an employment i
don't know yet but i've got the
information back there
we will have to look at the patients and
chips in traveler's sides
block policies are updated now um
because you started doing your planning
way back in i think it was a
be 10 or 11.
well we've had a few iterations of bmpf
since then
so because you had that two examinations
it took a very long time to bring your
plan forward
so when you approved your plan in 2017
actually some of your evidence
was was was already quite old in that
date
and he meant to have up-to-date evidence
for a local plan
so
the work that we're doing now is
bringing everything up to trains stuff
that we should really have done you know
maybe previously
so that's just all i'd say about the
local plan it is a legal requirement now
from a week ago actually
just a tiny bit to come back on that and
because i'm going to stop in a second
you've hit the nail on the head yeah
we're in a review so we can review it
how we determine we want the plan
reviewed so if we want to review it a
certain way i just don't think that a
policy review group of a small amount of
members is sufficient to give the full
council the in-depth knowledge and
information that they need and we can
choose you know with different versions
there's different build-out rates
there's different reports litchfield
liverpool sedgefield there's lots of
different methodologies but members
don't know about that
so members should be given the option to
be able to look at that and say this is
the route that we want you to go down as
officers to develop a plan that's robust
enough to give the district what it
needs going forward and that's all we
have to do
we don't have to do anything so we can
we can do that in that way
so yeah you're dead right some of the
policies may be old
but they might just need a tweak and
there's always that but it doesn't mean
to say fundamentally the plan is sound
it was found sound by the inspector
so why on earth would we want to go and
throw the baby out with a bath water
i i just think you you know i get what
you say but i think if i was on this
committee and i reiterated that again i
would be seriously concerned that i
wasn't involved in the whole of the
elected members in something that is as
important as this and using the
expertise of members
i just i just want to say that the fine
policy working group
is to all members so all members can
come to every single meeting and join in
so if you
want to be involved then you need to
come along to the working group meetings
yeah no and i don't want to be involved
in a working group meeting i want to i
want the full council to be sitting have
an extrapolation of detail and then
maybe look at a strategy going forth for
that so that's what i would be calling
for and because that's the only open and
transparent way and then looking at how
the strategy is going to be taken by
that group if that group is still
supported by council because council is
a sovereign here and i think we you know
i know myself
wasn't informed enough when this thing
came through i was put in a position of
fear because bradwell was going to be
built and 4 billion houses going to be
put up in a place where we didn't want
them
so i think there's a lot of questions
that would need to be asked by full
council
thank you for that
i've got two three people who want to
speak now do you want to come back on
that or not at the moment
no do you want me to carry on
are we now talking about the five new
supplier we're going to be talking about
the
local plan review because they have two
different things
let me take these two questions here
three questions then we'll move on to
that
thank you chairman my my point is that
the working group meets during the day
that ex that excludes people who work
and that's why it should be done with
all members in in an evening or
something when members can can attend
yeah so it's really important it's all
like saying the working groups open but
if you're working nine to five or
whatever you can't attend those meetings
chair
next one against the bill
thank you mr chairman i might actually
be going to take words out of council
spencer's mouth possibly but i was going
to make a proposal that in fact we do as
councillor suggests and we do bring this
to full count so i think it's the only
thing to do
and i'll second that okay um
do you want the wording from councillor
spencer or is that just sufficient
okay
here goes so let's see if you so what
i'd written i did have a little preamble
so if i can do that i'd be grateful
so it's terribly sorry to intercede
again but i believe procedurally the
proposer has to do the preamble so my i
withdraw my proposal and defer to you
counselor yes
thank you
thank you
um so it strikes me that what is most
called for here is balance
this is not about being nimby or
preventing growth and a supply of
housing at the level at which is needed
it is about achieving that while at the
same time ensuring that this rural
district is also protected against
potential overdevelopment that would in
turn provide the potential for key
infrastructure to fail for example the
supply of secondary school places an
issue that did not escape the inspector
at the examination of our current ldp
it is crucial that members own our local
development plan and its contents
this is the purpose of democracy in
action it is therefore also essential
that members understand and own the
methodology being used in the
construction of that plan in the course
of the current review
due to the confusion concerning the
methodology being used to calculate the
land supply i would like to propose that
this committee recommends to full
council that we pause the current review
methodology of the ldp and all members
are invited to an extraordinary meeting
of full council to consider options with
regard to the methodology used and to
consider a partial review of the ldp as
required rather than a full change to
the council's current strategy thank you
we had a second for that councillor maze
was it but yeah i'll second that i'd
also like a recorded vote on it please
record your vote okay record your vote
well you're right that's our recorded
vote
i can send you the wording tara
afterwards tonight thank you very much
can you read out the names
[Music]
as the chairman oliver stone
four
four
council morgan
four
and where do we go for do you want to
carry on with oh we've got two more
people councillor maze
uh yeah thank you mr chairman um could i
also propose that this meeting takes
place before next council which is not
due until the end of september
do i have a secondary
yes
okay
do you want to record your vote or just
buy a sin
in august buy sent thank you bye soon
because the next council meeting is
actually april september there's quite a
lot for us
remember the 8th of september good
enough
yes no
because they're on holiday they've got
four weeks holiday
is it
lots of members are anyway
okay yeah
if you you
check that and come back to me and
suspensely that's fine
um what else we've got yet counselor
folker thank you chairman i i mean look
the easy way to do this is is i i
believe 10 members can call a a special
meeting the council anyway so if 10
members
subscribe
to that motion tomorrow morning then you
can call it and i think the council has
to call it within four weeks and i think
i think given the intense interest in
this this evening and an impassioned i
think the sooner it's done the better
but jeremy if i can just return to what
i said before um i actually asked the
lead specialist planning and policy um
whether or not moving forward we could
actually
had a condition over delivery on these
sites and whether or not we could
restrict developers to a certain number
of units on their sites so that would
encourage multiple uh developers to
bring forward houses which we know they
will they will fight each other to
deliver
can we do that
can you repeat it again please
so for for
for the third time maybe i didn't make
myself clear before but what i said was
is the is it possible or legal
to condition application approvals
with uh a sum total sum total with
delivery so in other words they'd be
required to deliver so many houses i can
hear you i can say can i hear you i can
see you nodding but i do believe that
other local authorities do this and they
do it is possible to put a ceiling on it
is possible to put a ceiling on
developments i mean we we could do that
anyway but if somebody brings forward a
site with 1200 houses
you know they're always going to have
problems with delivery whereas if you've
got four developers bringing forward
four sites 300 the economics of it is is
that they will compete with each other
so there must be a way to control this
because i believe other
planning authorities do that
you can
there's a maximum quantum of development
that a developer will put forward on a
site and sometimes they come in with
more housing on that side and sometimes
that means that we can't force them
to be able to build at that exact amount
if they come in with an application for
less housing we can't make them
don't do that that's not something we
didn't make them do we can't make them
if
somebody owns one side so some
countryside didn't want to split their
sites up we can't force them to do that
there's no way that legally we can do
that if they do well that's that's
that's great you know that's that's fine
but under under the
present planning system we cannot force
people to split their sights
um it's just
we cannot force people to bring their
sights forward you know at the moment
we don't have the ability to
unless of course we want to compulsory
purchase sites and we can do that it's
got planning permission and it was part
of a wider regeneration
scheme yes we can do that but it's very
very expensive
so chairman i'm i'm still not sure if my
answer has been questioned
my question can you speak loudly yes
inside chairman i uh you know this is to
do with moving forward with policy and i
think we should examine whether or not
this is possible because i believe that
other local authorities do do this to
prevent one developer having a huge
rump of the five-year housing land
supply and then using that as leverage
in the district not to deliver i mean
one only has to look at
countryside plc's annual reports
um to actually
see almost what their
dark business plan is
we need to we need to possibly make
people um
what you call momentum book their
development so that you know if they're
they're hiding something or they're it's
not
you know
that's not the whole truth about what
they're saying they're going to bring
forward we need to think about doing
that more often but we can't make people
bring itself forward
it's just not
thank you for that any
counsellor um
yeah i mean i could be wrong but i i may
be misinterpreting what counselor fluke
is saying i think he's actually just
trying to ask that a policy is written
or included going forward
that that something can be said to
restrict the the same problems we've had
which is countryside which is the 1200
or whatever it was supposed to be on the
garden suburbs which the inspector
identified and said this is the high
risk strategy that this council has
adopted in this plan so what council
fluke i'm sure you'll tell me if i mean
if i'm wrong and he told me to be quiet
because i shouldn't be speaking on
behalf of him but he wants to try and
make it going forward we're not in the
same position so he's asking you to look
at the policy and writing a policy
fairly urgently to stop that happening
so in theory we're going for the smaller
sites again is that not right something
like that i could be wrong and through
you i mean i know that counselor stamp
when she was mrs stamp used to go went
to all the examinations in public but it
said i can remember some of this now i'm
having a bit of a flashback and that's
exactly what the inspector said now if
the inspector would not have questioned
that strategy and said that you know it
was risky unless there was a way to
control it in other words don't have a
developer with twelve hundred so i think
we need to go back and and and look at
the inspectors remarks because now i
remember that quite clearly which makes
me suggest that you know to me it
suggests that there is a way of
controlling this
you know i and and i do think knowing
david coleman as i do i'm sure you've
spoken to david coleman who led on the
local development plan before but i mean
he was a very very precise and concise
officer and he will have notes on all of
this
and uh yeah i'd say i mean it's an
interesting point the councillor stamp
raised with regards to the inspector's
comment which i now remember
okay
um
i think you'll still
think there is a way you can write a
policy that forces the developer to
split a site up all that
locations this time is having bigger
baskets yeah different sizes yep
i think it's 10
on smaller sites anyway but we need to
think about having expanding that basket
so we've got a wider choice to the
market you're loving big size of course
but there should be some smaller sites
as well
okay
do you want to carry on with what you
were trying to do
fun
um
strategy seemed logical on the surface
it seems like a logical strategy it was
sustainable it put growth in sustainable
places and on the odd service that just
looked like a
sensible way forward the inspector said
yes it is ambitious
but there were some things in your
trajectory that perhaps nowadays when we
were looking at site allocations we
won't be doing
so for instance side to age which is
heydrich swift
is
and 101 homes but it's it's going to be
really difficult to deliver it hasn't
come forward because it has to
uh provide another sports provision so
now if that site came forward now
we we as officers would not recommend
that site to be allocated we would find
another site that would quite clearly be
easier to
deliver because it's very difficult to
find an alternative sports provision and
what you should have done really in the
plan
is shown how that side was going to
provide that alternative provision and
it didn't do that the plan didn't do
that
the other thing is
we had a windfall allowance it wasn't
very high in the plan but
i don't know what size things were
there was no there was no way
it wasn't set out clearly in the plan
how these 300 homes were going to be
delivered
and so what we would do nowadays is say
we will actually locate sites up to 300
hours and we won't have a win for
allowance in a plan at all you have to
allocate your full allowance
so
it's not going to put it on we're going
to have 300 thousands or 500 or 600 and
they're going to come forward or through
fox they might not they might not come
through windfall is not planned so you
don't know where it's going to come or
what's going to happen so you either got
to allocate the number or you've got to
set out really clearly how you expect it
to come forward
the other thing was you have no slippage
in the plan at all
um if you always get some slippage in
your planning application so you need to
put a certain rate the district interest
rate is very low 74.5 cents only
national work language is about any exam
but you should think about putting a
slippage rate into your trajectory
the other thing in the trajectory there
was a hundred tokens for neighbourhood
plans in edinburgh plans but they didn't
say where that's going to happen or how
it was going to happen or which which
settlements were going to provide it and
they haven't done that so that 100 homes
now as we were allocating we would
allocate them on on a on a separate site
because the neighbourhood plan shouldn't
technically
be bringing forward more housing than
it should be additional housing not just
housing to make up your trajectory
um
so
there's a there's a few issues that
we've picked up that we can you know we
can just sort out next time around and
we just won't we won't make those
mistakes again
um
so you've asked us you've asked us how
how we're going to
monitor
we took out the windfall allowance from
the five-year supply because in national
policy
you can only use the windfall allowance
if it delivers a significant part of
your housing and it doesn't deliver a
significant part of malden's housing so
it should never have been in there in
the first place and so we have removed
that
um the plan policies the policies in the
plan i mean this is just our officer
opinion they're not very clear they're
not very positive they have lots of
constraining caveats in them so when
developers come forward so you're in a
position you haven't got a five inch fly
so what you need to do
is ground positions
in order to get the supply
but people try to put plan permission in
and your plan means that you can't grant
those commissions because there's too
many constraints too many caveats in
your plan that
almost constrain you
and officers to say no
and a lot of the policies
they start with the premise of saying no
and that's that's not how local plans
are written nowadays there's they're
starting to start with the president we
will support development
and yes you can put capillaries in
because you know that
is always going to be a bad sign you
know if a local bioware authority comes
along and says that access is rubbish
the site
so some of the policies of the plan
definitely do need reviewing they are
evidenced out
and that is part of the reason
that you you know you're struggling with
your final supply
so just as an example
i had a quick look to see how many
houses this council has approached from
the first of april so we've only
approved for
so
that's not that's not very
at cool we're completing 22.
you've completed 22
that means you're 18 down again
on a five-year supply
so getting all the time
supply is going to drop
and the reason that you can't approve
any more than once you've approved
is because you're struggling with your
plan
yeah
that's the reason yeah
are you able to take another couple of
questions
yeah you want to yeah
thank you mr chairman i mean you know
clearly
the plan probably it must be reviewed
and will be reviewed but those policies
are put into the plan to make sure that
growth isn't just spread out in rural
areas where there's no infrastructure i
mean those policies are there for a
purpose
so i kind of feel as as council language
said that you are
arguing for us
you know not to have a five-year land
spy rather than arguing for it so it's a
bit like
it's a bit like um i know it's a bit
like talking to your accountant with
your accounts and saying you know these
are my accounts and should we go to the
tax office and the and the accountant's
saying yeah but you know do you want to
put some a few expenses in do you want
to you know and and you would say yes
and so you would go with we've been very
pedantic about this about this plan i
mean but the plan is there
with a reason and the policies are in
the plan for a reason and so just to say
that the plan is rubbish and these
policies are not good enough you know
yes they need reviewing
but i i cannot you know i cannot agree
with you that this the ldp is not is not
robust right just a quick one from
councillor stamp very quick please and
wants to get on yeah i know chairman
what i'd like to say to um is that this
council isn't averse to ex to approving
planning um planning
approvals
what what we're trying to ascertain is
that the any planning goes with the
infrastructure delivery and that is the
issue we've got and i know you know
you're going to turn around which matt
lee always says it's not my
responsibility it says it's counter
council it's somebody else who have to
do that but what we've got to understand
is we have got to make our policies
stronger we've got to make it so you
know instead of at the end of a thousand
houses you get your 500 that grand or
whatever it's got to be somehow
negotiated or we've got to look at a
plan or look at a law to actually try
and change that because you can't keep
building on in this district not you
personally without schools without
doctors without roads without buses
without trains i mean with all we've got
now chairman is two direct trains that
go into liverpool street the first time
you've got to stop at wickford now if
you're disabled i've got a buggy how do
you get over the other side yet there's
lots of logistical problems if we are
rewriting our plan we need to take it
into account chairman so it's not a
question it's a statement right okay
councillor just a very very quick one
and then we must carry on there's a i
think i think it's very important though
and thank you again for indulging me i
think that paragraph 70 of the mpf talks
about windfalls
and where there's evidence to be made
for in full size as part of supply there
should be compelling evidence that they
will provide a reasonably source of
supply so i don't think it's saying
that it should they shouldn't be there i
just think we've got to be very careful
how we we allocate them because there
will always be windfall sites the
district has those
i think we've got two thousand uh
granted permissions as well and finally
what counselor stampers said and i think
it's also an elephant that's not in the
room is if we just charge you wrong
doing the things we're doing you know
school places
do you think as a member do you think
it's really potential distance is travel
in 75 minutes as this is county council
says acceptable and for residents in
malden for you know
then fanbridge and other places to send
their kids to school each way because
that's what they allow so give us a
quick
she wants to listen to the
people i want to listen to everyone ever
since but anne's trying to present
something as you're getting very
frustrated by not being able to get on
with it aren't you
okay
it's monitored
it used to be
um
[Music]
and have a look at the information we
use building control council tax cybits
our uniform database
so we do you used to do it
yearly we would create separate tables
we would monitor
the section one and fit stuff the rams
information and our housing
three three three separate ways and so
we were almost triple handling
information and it was quite complicated
we weren't particularly looking at
trends in terms of parish growth or
anything like that and because we were
doing it yearly
um
if there was there's more and foreign to
be honest i think because
lots of things can happen on the side in
a year
so you're looking at lots of different
places for information
so what we do now
is we do it weekly so every single week
i
look at the building control records i
have a look at what's been going on if
anything's coming if i've got any
information or information from anywhere
really sometimes i'll send the team out
on site to have a look at sites so we do
that every week and then that feeds
directly into the section 106 monitoring
and demands payments monitoring so we're
only doing it once rather than
uh three people talking it and having
different places to monitor it
and then we publish of course once a
year that will have this year reserve
the right to
publish again in six months
so
this matter of the five-year supply has
been raised as far back as 2019
um
at the corporate performance governance
logic committee
it's a corporate performance in
indicator so it's been around it's added
to the corporate risk register in 2017
2018
um so it's been hovering around for
quite some time
hopefully we are now more efficient at
monitoring it so it's all done on one
excel spreadsheet now so i can tell you
at any given moment what the five-year
supply is
that's how i know um
how many houses we've you know we we
gained permission for and we have
actually completed since the first of
april
so what can we do to solve
the of difficulty
well we're carrying out
of the lgp and i just want to say the
way that you work out five-year supply
is not the same as the way you work out
the possible climate requirement for
uh
is a completely different methodology
and it comes up with a completely
different figure
um
which we will be discussing with members
of the 9th of august
so we're doing it
so when we do that we need to ensure
that the healthy trajectory that we
bring forward is going to be realistic
this time and deliverable islamic
national policy so that means we're
going to have to work do a lot of work
with the developers and yes i'm not
saying that we did it last time but we
need to make sure it's realistic that's
the one lesson i think maybe we really
need to learn from this
we need to make sure that our housing
allocations provide choice in the
housing market
so that we do have smaller sites and
that will help your sme builders in the
district as well because i think they're
a little bit squeezed out at the moment
um we need to make sure that we allocate
our whole allowance but we don't have
things that important
that are have big question marks over
them that we don't really know what's
going to happen
to them
we need to make sure that our policies
are positively written now that doesn't
mean that you
just give permission for everything it
doesn't mean this kind of
urban sprawl i think is one of the words
that a lot of the faculties used in the
issues and options consultation what it
means is that your policy starts with
the premise that we will support
and then you you go from that point
onwards
so that you you then change your whole
mindset about planning that you you know
you support you look for the good things
rather than look for the bad things and
then if it doesn't mean you're going to
be giving permission to bad sites it
doesn't mean you're going to be
concreting over the countryside it just
means a different way of writing and
policies that you are easier and clearer
to understand
for both yourselves and for the people
putting planning applications in you
know at the moment
your employment policy doesn't set out
clearly what happens if somebody doesn't
want to have employment land it doesn't
say how long they've got to advertise
that solo it doesn't say where they got
to do that so when you come forward to
making a decision it's really difficult
to do that because we haven't set out
clearly what the criteria are for moving
from one use to another use
so these things they need to be
sorted out
we need to make sure
that the evidence base supporting the
lgp reviews for augustine it's up today
because there's
quite a lot of it is not up to date at
the moment
we need to make sure that all our
meetings are meeting clearly we have a
clear forwarding trail which we are
doing as a matter of course and actually
we need to make sure that we cultivate
this is for the five-year supply not the
lgp we cultivate a more pro-growth
culture in the council so we start from
the premise
that side could be okay
and then we move to well what's wrong
with it
so at the moment i think we've been with
a plan this is just my view looking in
from the outside coming from other
authorities is that we start with
premises we don't we're not good for
this and i think that makes it quite
difficult
as i said earlier
you could have a hundred years supply of
housing but a bad side is still a bad
sign it it's completely a new point
really you could have no supply of
housing but if you a site comes in and
the highway authority are going to
object it because it's got a dangerous
access can't be mitigated against it
it's next to a heritage site and you
can't mitigate it's still a bad sign
she's still refusing it so it doesn't
make any difference to live by new
supply
um
so the other that's the other thing is
what had impact has been 5-year supply
had on the development plan and pending
reviews but there was a trigger
and we didn't we didn't meet that
trigger in in in the plan so that
triggered a review but now now i said
earlier it's a new point because
actually we've now passed the legal
requirement and we have we have to
review the plan
um
the only the only other point is
which is a bit of a positive is we do
know
that sides eventually do come forward so
it's not as though we've got a lot of
allocations that are sitting there that
haven't even started you know
no we do know that actually having to
live with housing delivery itself the
completion of heritage is quite robust
in the district you know on writing
delivery tests we're passing it but
and that gives us confidence when we're
doing our site allocations that what we
do okay will come forward it's just with
the trajectory that we set we need to
make sure it's robust and realistic and
what we also need to do
is make sure that the infrastructure
that we need actually just tie up with
that projector being at the moment the
english system you know nobody knows
nobody likes the english system of the
word running forward infrastructure
it is triggers and if it's a large
infrastructure it's not going to come
until the late faces of the plan that's
the way the system is set up and it will
have to change nationally
in order to change
um and then at the moment the council
can't do anything about that except
as
an authority you know in itself you know
try and campaign nationally to change
that
okay
um yes the passenger you wanted a quick
question yeah just so yeah i mean just
just going way way back we were talking
about things that we need to do and i
think there are two things that we
definitely need to do
in one and one of those
both those things one is to define
exactly what is meant by sustainable and
sustainability because that is just
purely subjective
and again i think we need to define what
is meant in our policy by demonstrative
harm and these two things come up every
single time whenever you question
anything you always said well it's not
sustainable or it is the same you say
okay what is that
it's all sort of no one ever knows what
what it means it has no diff it has no
substance
can you ask that please then
it is
subjective isn't it
because
the members used to say that if they
didn't have growth in smaller villages
that they wouldn't be sustainable so
when i asked what that meant
they couldn't tell me and i couldn't
really tell them either it you know as
far as real concerns if something's
sustainable it means it can sustain
itself
so
if somebody
if we're looking for
um i'm trying to think of an example now
if we're looking for a ceremony for site
locations we want them to be
in places where people could at least
get a kind of milk and um the london
bread
is it one of the measures really again
about school places isn't that that
something that you can sort of measure
sustainability by whereas you know if
you've got sorry if you've got say
500 primary school places and you've
only got 400 secondary school places
then you know we are you you can see
there there's just not enough school
places if you're sending people 75
minutes away to schools because your
area has no school place or it has no
doctors but mainly school places is
really the measure that we that that we
can use
it's about it is one of the factors and
it's one of the things that the county
council are very keen on in terms of
which options for growth we take forward
i don't particularly want to talk about
the consultation responses here at this
meeting because they should be
discussing that's right yeah but i have
to say that education
um
it is a key factor and it has come out
and the consultation is a key factor and
it is something that we need to take
into account when we're making our
deliberations and we will be discussing
it um it's probably in september at the
policy working group
okay
did you want to come back counselor
standing to ask a question um and very
kindly referred to the build-out rates
and about it being national and that
we'd have to
go to government or lobby is there a
current
minimum a maximum build out rate for
every site
so so so so okay so my product question
to that is is it down to this council to
negotiate under the section 106 to agree
for completed properties before monies
is released
uh yes
if part of the negotiations in terms of
um
so what happens is when we go into
negotiation with say education
contributions
the county
to tell us what triggers they want in
terms because they work out how much
funding
they
they need in order and when they need it
so it's the county or the health service
tell us where the triggers are for our
own
um
infrastructure we negotiate it ourselves
you know so if it's um so it's
allotments or something like that then
that's what we're even going to show you
please can i ask what our policy is on
that then please
we must surely there's a standard policy
for all
um um ldp sites that is pretty standard
so x amount of house you'd get your 8
grand or 20 houses built for your
allotments 30 houses for your youth
facilities etc surely something's
written somewhere
okay councillor bill
thank you chairman
i find it totally amazing after looking
at all the
lists that we get every week about
planning applications
and
it's a it's a known fact that modern
district council has got the lowest
uh rate in the whole country for
accepting planning applications
um so
if we would i mean
we're told it's the presumption that it
will be agreed
and then you've got a council that are
turning everything and anything down
and that would be classed up as zoomers
landfall because you'd have houses built
because anne was saying we're not
getting the houses um through the
through that
so if they were accepting
anything yeah any planning application
that would increase our our level of
housing
also
and i think councillor samps just
mentioned it there should be an
infrastructure levy on every
development whether it's a brand new
house or 40 new houses there should be
some sort of chart where they pay x
amount for every new house they're
building because then it would give you
the infrastructure yeah we've got the
answer coming up and
the council did consider
the community infrastructure levy but by
the time you got to
your examination on the local plan
a lot of the strategic sites have
planned permission so once someone's got
planning permission if you have if you
have planning permission ahead of
community infrastructure level you can't
ask for any leverage so what you were
left with in terms of levy
was not really worth the effort to be
honest you're getting more out of sexual
assaults now the government are
proposing to change the way
infrastructure is funded we don't know
how yet we have hints that it's going to
be a levy a national level but and this
is going to raise alarm bells and it's
raising alarm bells with us the the
funding will come in on completion of
the site
so if your site takes 10 years to build
you're not going to get it funding until
10 years at the end so that's what we
heard
but whether that would translate into
legislation i don't know
okay that
cancer lagging quick one please
thank you council hillary
um
the letter that mr dodson sent back that
came back from the department of
levening up where malcolm cove was
in charge of that um it does seem to be
that there there's going to be a
fundamental change where the planning is
going to be more community-led
which to me strikes as a good thing
because we need more community
involvement
and so this is why i'm really pleased
that this committee from a
scrutinization perspective has handed it
back to the council to have a look at
this um because we need to consider what
what could be because the five-year
housing land supply might not be the
measure i don't think it's the legal
measure uh the delivery test of 154
percent we're exceeding is really really
good um
there are there are permissions we we do
plan we do give planning permission you
know the council looks you know we don't
sit there
and go no no no you look at something
and you'll think you know how do we look
at something and say that it's best for
the communities
and then look at the officers
recommendations and only argue if it's
strong for that so i think we've got we
mustn't forget that national policy may
be changing um so this throws so many
things into into question
a word of um really
you don't have a five-year supply that
means that there are many applications
in the pipeline
that will come in as well we call them
hostile applications yes they're not
they're not planned they're with full
they're going to be quite large yeah and
there are quite a lot of them in the
pipeline yeah so the worst case scenario
we were talking about this today our
team meeting to be honest
we have work we've worked out what the
housing requirement is going to be um
over a period 15 20 25 years so we've
worked that out
and we we we know roughly what we need
in the big pieces of infrastructure i
don't want to go into too much detail
here but the word of caution is that we
could end up by default
granting lots of planning permissions
because we don't have a choice because
we're trying to make up our ideal supply
and ending up not having enough housing
to allocate to pay for the
infrastructure that we really need
and that's a real dangerous
because the longer things go on
the bigger the risk that is and so what
you end up with is lots of housing that
you don't really want
in places that maybe you're not that
keen on that's not planned that has no
infrastructure attached to it
and you end up with it by default
we're almost in a race
we need to get the we need to get stuff
sorted out quickly so that you're in a
better position
so just a
uh probably in august
thank you very much for ann you've got
nothing more to add have you
right thank you very very much for that
we've got
uh two recommendations tara is that
correct
yes
are the first ones the please considers
the officer's response out of pending
day and whether it provides sufficient
assurance and understanding of the
background to decide
to make recommendations to the council
or other committee as required
a recommendation too that the committee
identifies any further basis and plan
for more detailed scrutiny in films
being required
right members
are we proposing to take these both
recommendations in one go
or do you want alternative
recommendations i know it's going to
council but we've got some here we've
got to do
or are you prepared just to go to
council and that's it
the
do not have to put those recommendations
and if they fight if it fails then the
recommendation for the have a proposal
all right i'll put the first
recommendation that the committee
considers the officer response
at appendix a and whether it provides
sufficient assurance and understanding
of the background
to this item
to make recommendations council
or other committees as required
no okay
item two that the committee identifies
any further basis and plan for more
details scrutiny it felt to be required
members
agreed
okay is that sufficient tyler
for more detail right okay right
all right we want to identify councillor
bell um may i propose mr chairman that a
working group is formed because i
believe there's far far too much for us
to make an instant decision on what that
is
and we'll have that in a minute
okay are you happy with that happy that
tara
okay
yes because it's going to council so
that's the word oh well okay it's going
to counselling so that's it the end of
that at the moment
there's nothing in perspective of
identifying any further basement plan
for more detailed scripting
members
are you agreeing or disagree if you
disagree with one item to go to scrutiny
again
members
my understanding and members please chip
in my understanding is that we aren't
happy with it it does need more scrutiny
but this is why it's going to count
okay
is that sufficient to to comply with the
recommendation tara
okay
all in favor
right that's past right
now we move on to
item number eight
if i can get to it
i think i've got a
working group and over over in scrutiny
um
to establish the working of the overuse
scrutiny recommended for members of the
overview scrutiny are adopted
appointed to sit on the working group
from the chair of light to prosecute
suspension myself councillor hubner and
councillor bell
are all in favor
right okay
is that right tara
move on to
yeah that is a grief
agenda item nine
apartment representative on liaison
committee
councillor mays was the previous
representative would you like to carry
on
i guess please mr chairman thank you
secondly can i propose for a second of
them
you got that
thank you mr chairman
all right what else we've got here now
[Laughter]
we're having having problems here
any items of business that the chairman
declares are urgent
the only thing we need is more
items to scrutinize please can you fill
in the forms and send them in so we do
certain items please
so i don't want anyone to say we've got
nothing to scrutinize i've had that said
to me before and uh it's not very nice
when you try and do something you can't
get them thank you very much members we
close the meeting at nine o'clock